if someone has actually never seen any
of your work before what is the first
thing you want them watching and why
i would have them start at the beginning
just in the order i made them because uh
i think you know that's been my journey
as a filmmaker in every film i've
learned
uh
something new and and tried to apply
that to the next one so
um that's i guess that's i guess that's
my answer
which of the films changed the most in
the editing room you know what gosh
they're all i feel like they're all kind
of really true to the script i mean um
we certainly honed this one
uh
you know because we had we didn't have
the time pressure at the end um
but uh
yeah they all stayed pretty true you
know i've never had a film that like
went through a massive restructure or
you know rebuild at the end
um if you get the financing to make
anything you want
uh what would you make and why
you know when i was a kid uh in high
school i loved the book the fountainhead
uh and you know making that as like a
period 1930s film would be pretty epic
so i read that you went to paris when
tom was filming mission
to pitch him on you know on top gun
maverick how much did you had you talked
previously about the project or was this
like your first time actually talking to
him you know tom says we we talked about
it on oblivion uh
but it was probably very general and
very you know very high level
um uh tom was shooting mission jerry you
called me in um
and they had a script they had been
working on which i read and it and it
gave me you know
i had some ideas about how i would do it
differently i guess i would say
and when i pitched jerry kind of my
approach he said well we gotta go
you gotta talk to tom about this
directly so let's go to paris
he was shooting mission
six uh and we went out there and uh we
found you know a half hour break in the
day
uh mchugh is very generous to let tom go
for a half hour
and um
i think what i didn't realize and jerry
was probably smart not to tell me was
that tom really didn't want to do
another top gun movie
i think he walked into that room
uh
prepared to say thank you for coming all
this way and i appreciate it but you
know
i'm not interested in making another
movie um
and then uh at the end of that meeting
he uh he picked up the phone and he
called
the head of the studio and said we're
making another top gun so that was a
pretty
that was a pretty epic meeting uh and
pretty amazing to see
you know that
level of power uh on display
what was it like though had you been
praying like when you're going to sit
down with tom and obviously you've
worked with him before are you actually
like practicing your pitch on the plane
when you're flying over or are you just
thinking about it and how you're gonna
you know what i mean
i was very more conversational i mean i
had kind of my
four big kind of
ideas um
that i wanted to talk through i had you
know i had some visuals i had some
videos um i had a poster i had a title
you know i had kind of like the big
stuff but it was really
the the most important thing was the
story and it was this
character journey of maverick and what
it was going to be i mean that was the
that was the thing i think that really
got him hooked was
there was finally something that he
could latch onto emotionally which was
this you know this reconciliation with
um
with goose's son i mean that was the you
know that drew on what was most powerful
and people remembered the most from the
first film which is that friendship with
goose
and then you know i just like looking at
that little kid with the cowboy hat
sitting on the piano in that scene in
the first movie and thinking about him
growing up
and and and what that would mean if he
became a naval aviator and maverick had
to send him into combat um
[Music]
what that would feel like and i think
that's where tom finally said you know
what
that's it that's what
that's what's worth coming back for you
obviously had your release date punted
about 27 times and i'm i'm just curious
when you have that much more time are
you going back into the edit uh like in
2021 2022 or what when did you actually
finish this movie we finished the cut in
2020 pretty close to when the movie was
supposed to come out originally
um you know then we all went off and
made other films um which was good we
all stayed busy
uh certainly we had time to do a couple
little finishing touches to the the mix
and the picture um
we didn't have to rush anything like i
i'm
in hindsight that extra time was good to
just make sure it was exactly as we
wanted
uh but the cut was locked i mean the
movie even from the very first preview
was always uh always felt like it was on
really solid ground you know
a lot of people are very excited about
lady gaga contributing a song to the
soundtrack had you gotten her for the
soundtrack way back when or was this a
new addition in the last like year no
this was back in
2019 um we first
uh she wrote the song and and we heard
it played at the uh record label
went down there and and they played it
for us which is nerve wracking as jerry
would say because they're about to play
a song from a superstar and
what if you don't like it you know what
do you say
and uh luckily you know from the first
time we heard it we were like that's it
you know somehow
she just wrote a classic melody that um
that that works and then when hans
zimmer heard it he you know orchestrated
the score uh the love theme around that
melody so it it's um
it was pretty amazing to uh to see how
powerful that song is and how he was
able to weave it into the score were you
nervous at all because obviously this
song has been done for a while have you
been like dreading this song leaking
prior to the movie coming out
uh no because you know you're you're
always sitting on stuff you know you're
sitting on these files and and the
picture and and the trailers um so uh no
i mean it's like you know we're all
professionals we know how that stuff
needs to be handled and and you know
you're not blasting in your car you know
out in public or
um
but i'm excited that people are finally
going to get to hear it uh yeah i'm
still waiting to hear the unreleased
daft punk songs from tron legacy just
throwing that out i might see you next
time i see you we'll we can listen to
those together right
uh so um you and tom clearly have a
great working relationship uh during the
making of maverick or even in the last
year or two have you guys had those
conversations of so what are we gonna do
next i mean i'm always thinking about it
obviously having that relationship is a
pretty amazing thing um
it's just about figuring out like what
would what's that story you know he uh
he's obviously got his plate full with
missions for the next year or two
uh and then you know i hear he's going
to space after that uh so he's a busy
guy but um i'm always you know thinking
about looking for something that would
be great to work with him on i'm always
amazed that that tom is able to get
insurance on his movies um so
are you ever like do you get involved in
those conversations with the studio and
insurance are you sort of like you got
it right okay let's go
i never ask i just you know i just
shoot uh and uh yeah i don't ask those
questions
um obviously tony scott directed the
first one and i am
um you obviously have to
balance the nostalgia while also making
your own movie and i'm specifically
talking about shots that could be
inspired by tony scott so can you sort
of talk about where that line was when
you were directing like oh i want to
homage tony i want to nod tony you know
what i mean yeah yeah no i've never used
like sunset grads in my
in my footage before that's certainly a
tony scott thing and you know
tony created a world it's like it's like
the top gun cinematic universe where the
sun is always setting
everything's backlit everyone looks
great you know it's like
it's it's a look and a feel and i wanted
this film you know just as maverick gets
called back to top gun i really wanted
the audience to feel like they were
going back to top gun as well
um so that first you know
five minutes of the movie tells you
you're in a top gun film but then
you know we get into that opening
sequence and it becomes its own thing
you know it becomes its own film um that
looks very different and the last half
hour of the film looks
takes that top gun aesthetic and flips
it on its head and becomes something
totally opposite so
um i wanted it to feel like a top gun
movie the first movie set the bar very
very high you know cinematically
uh and claudio and i knew that you know
we'd have to meet that bar and try to
exceed it with some of this aerial
photography so that's
you know we did our best and you know i
guess the audience will decide if we
were successful uh the answer is yes um
talk a little bit about working actually
with claudio on um like the color scheme
that you were going for and the look you
were going for um and you know just
collaborating with him on the
cinematography yeah no we uh like said
we wanted it to feel like i wanted
people to be able to put the first movie
up in our movie and feel like not it
says the same you know we don't want the
cover band version of top gun but that
it feels like it's in the same universe
so
um you know we shot with the very the
long lenses on the ground uh the wide
angles up in the sky you know we have
those deep shadows
um that grade that just feels like uh
the first film we actually
developed a film grain that is a close
match to the
film stock that was used on the first
film even though we shot digitally
so i haven't added you know i haven't
used film grain in a film i've done
before but for this one it just made
sense because it didn't really feel like
top gun until you had that on there
and it just i just wanted it to feel
uh like a top gun film and there's some
of those you know things that do that um
it was fun it was fun to you know live
in that universe how did you and claudio
decide what cameras you wanted to use i
know i believe you shot some imac stuff
um and can you sort of talk about the
cameras you chose to use on the film
yeah well we um
claudia and i had been working with sony
on a new prototype camera we just shot a
short film called the dig with something
new called the sony venice
which is a 6k very high quality camera
that is certified by imax as being
it's not made by imax but it it's imax
quality and that'll hold up at 100 foot
screen
uh and then we worked with them they
were they were developing a prototype
where you can take the venice camera and
split it into two pieces so that the
sensor and the lens is one piece and
then you have a fiber optic cable
connecting you to the recorder which is
separate
and what that allows is the actual
sensor and camera can be a very small
box
um
that allows you to put it in very small
places
so we worked closely with the navy to
get clearance to put um at first we want
to get one
then two then four and then we finally
end up with six
uh in the in the cockpit
um
by taking out all this other equipment
they didn't need and uh we were able to
just capture you know all those
interiors
for real which is
you know you just can't fake that you
can't fake the forces on your body and
the way the light moves around the
canopy and
the way the terrain sweeps by the the
lens um
we got that all for real and uh
you know just it just it's a it's an
old-school way of making a film but with
you know
new technology i don't know how many of
these cameras are actually in existence
like do they have tons of these cameras
or was new yeah we were the first to use
it but now they're widely used and in
fact they've just come out with the
venice 2
which is a successor so we're going to
look you know obviously start looking at
that and see what see what that's like
for me seeing val kilmer in the movie
meant a lot and i'm and i'm can you sort
of talk about getting to work with val
and just making sure he was in the movie
yeah we all uh
wanted to figure out a way for iceman to
be in the film
uh
val came in and met with jerry and i and
he
um
he actually had the idea of how to
integrate himself into the film
which was incredible
and uh you know to work with someone
like him of his caliber you know some of
my favorite characters you know like his
character in heat is one of my all-time
favorites
uh to get to work with him
in one of his most iconic roles and then
to be able to to do a scene with him and
tom together
uh and see that relationship which has
developed you know over the last 35
years that rivalry between the
characters to become the friendship it
is in this film
um it's very emotional to be there for
to film that scene but
uh you know it's also one of my favorite
to watch in the movie i don't want to
spoil it but there's a great line at the
end of that sequence um was that who
came up with that line because it's so
good that was a line in the script uh
that um we loved and we you know we
played around with this thing we played
with versions that had it out and had it
in and i'm so glad we put it in because
you know i was at cinemacon
uh and uh it was great just to see
how the audience reacted oh it uh uh a
hundred percent um the
obviously the navy uh you needed the
navy to sign off on this movie um
was it one of these things where when
you guys approached them it was almost
like oh you're making a top gun sequel
yes
yes on the first movie it wasn't that
way from what i understand with jerry um
but you know given how the first movie
was received and what it did for the
navy
i'm the benefit of was being able to
walk in there and have them say
yes what would you like where would you
like to shoot what do you need and um so
we got to shoot not only on the carrier
and on the bases that you would expect
but we got to shoot in some places that
you know
people would never get to see you know
the public never gets to see
uh top secret spaces um
uh so it was it was a pretty amazing uh
opportunity was there anything that you
guys asked for that they actually said
this is a little too top secret we can't
do that uh yeah i i went to some there
were a couple of times where uh i took
some pictures that um had to be erased
off my camera um things like that you
know wandering around some of these
spaces but uh
but uh you know they did a good job of
kind of keeping the secret stuff secret
and uh and you know we got to put our
our stuff in place so you shot on the
roosevelt um and uh i believe this was
the name of the ship but shout out we've
got the roosevelt and on the lincoln
so my question is with when you're
shooting on those kinds of
uh ships uh you know um is there
parameters before you step on foot on on
the boats that basically it's like you
have three days or you can shoot this
you know um could you sort of explain
that yeah we uh we were on uh uh the
roosevelt we were on the lincoln for a
few days and then we were on the
roosevelt for two weeks
um
basically you know they were in the
middle of doing their training
operations uh so
um there were windows during the day
where they had full-on flight operations
going where we could shoot from certain
places to get that footage
but between their flight operations when
the deck was quiet was when we could go
out and do our scenes
that we needed to do
and then there were times where you know
they were practicing catapult launches
where you know we were able to get tom
in the plane and you know we launched
him off that carrier i think four or
five times
uh and to capture that in camera you
know you obviously you see it in the
trailer you see it in the film
um it was a very difficult environment
to work in i mean my bunk was right
under
the uh where the wire was that catches
the plane so all night long and they're
running night outs all night so
you know you're not getting any sleep
you're working long days uh but there's
just no replacement for being on the
real thing yeah well the footage of tom
taking off is like jaw-dropping at what
point did you realize oh oh wow this is
really going to look good
uh you know i think our first aerial
test that we did with tom
we did a test day right at the beginning
of the shoot just to kind of work out
the kinks and we sent him
up with a top gun pilot to fly
some of the low-level training routes
around fallon nevada uh and which
eventually became
that sequence in the middle of the film
where
maverick flies the the the root alone
um and when that footage came back um
uh i think we all knew we had something
special i believe and i read i could be
wrong that at some points you had 27
cameras going
um when when did you have 27 cameras was
that on the boats
no that was probably out in fallon when
we were running uh
we were running two cameras with actors
in them or sorry two airplanes with
camera with actors in them six cameras
each so that's 12 cameras
on actor interiors we're probably
running two jets with exterior cameras
two each so that's another four
then we had you know probably two or
three ground units which are two cameras
each shooting ground to air
then we had an air to air unit
which is either jet to jet or helicopter
to jet
and then i may have had some cameras on
the runway too doing takeoffs and
landings
so yeah i think there was a day where
just because of all the activity that
was going on
uh we had that many cameras and then
obviously eddie hamilton in the trailer
just getting that amount of footage in
it was just non-stop you know just
combing through it all
uh it was pretty epic that that's
actually what i wanted to ask you about
uh you i read that you had as much
footage as lord of the rings you know
making this movie how the hell do you
edit something like that when you have
so much footage of flying and so many
cameras capturing great looks you know
what i mean like where how do you figure
that out like because i'm sure you have
multiple shots that look great yeah no
you're you're combing through it all
you're looking for those
moments like it could be a second
where the sun glints off the lens you
know on a shot on the belly of the plane
and the vapes are coming off the wings
and you just get like those moments that
are so special
and you're just combing through you find
that you put it in a bin save it and
then you you know scroll through the
next 45 minutes till you get another one
um
so like i said we had an incredible
editorial team eddie hamilton
uh who's uh just an incredible editor
uh spent i think the whole summer of
2019 basically
assembling that third act sequence just
the first assembly took him like three
months to put the first pass at that
together uh you know i like talking
about editing did you i know i think the
movie's a little over two hours i
apologize i don't know the final run
time what was like your first cut did
you have an original director's cut that
was like two and a half hours or was it
always about two hours no we didn't i
didn't do a director's cut we really
just started putting the movie together
um as we shot it um so i think you know
by the time we had finished shooting we
just had a
a film uh first pass it was probably 2
35 i would say
um uh to have everything in there um but
very quickly we were you know cutting it
down and
and so
uh
there's a couple scenes you know they're
left out there's a couple like there's a
shot in the tray the first trailer of
maverick looking up at the f-14 on the
stick
things like that that didn't make it in
um
but for the most part it was just about
you know the shot or the scene had to be
pretty good to make it into this cut i
would imagine that the theatrical
release is your cut your director's cut
is there for the blu-ray or maybe i'm
just asking but for the blu-ray are you
going to include like a longer cut of
the film or is it just deleted scenes
you know i don't know if we've decided
what we're going to put on the blu-ray
yet um
there i think there will only be one cut
this is the best cut you know we could
come up with there aren't multiple cuts
there's not extended versions uh
but uh yeah i'm not sure if we're gonna
do those other scenes or not tom has
this great chemistry with jennifer
connelly in the movie like it's it's
just really good was that um did you
guys do some sort of rehearsals or was
that just because they're great actors
uh they're great actors um they've both
been working a long time they kind of
both grew up in the business jen's maybe
been working longer than tom because she
started in
once upon a time in america um
that was her first film
so you know i just done a movie with jen
uh
and just had an incredible experience
working with her and i thought
that she would make a great penny
benjamin it's amazing they had never
crossed paths in their careers um
and uh yeah from the first moment you
know they were together i was like this
is this is gonna be great um
so uh
yeah she's she's fantastic in the film
when you think back on the making of the
film i'm sure there was a million tough
days or days where you thought i don't
know how we're getting through this but
what's like a day or two that you really
thought we're not gonna get through this
like i don't know how we're getting
these shots
you wouldn't believe this the aerial
stuff was was really really tough and
challenging to get but one of the
hardest scenes to get because it was
largely had factors that are out of my
control was the sailing sequence
with uh when penny and maverick go out
on that racing boat
um the first two times i tried to shoot
it we had no wind so it was me jen and
tom sitting on this
boat out in the middle of the san diego
bay you know with like nothing happening
it was like the worst
uh and there's nothing we could do about
it because um
the weather wasn't cooperating so we
ended up
after two times striking out with wind
uh we went up to san francisco
and shot that scene in the san francisco
bay where it's windy all the time
apparently
and uh and we had everything but you
know if you see that scene it's like
it's uh it's the real deal you know it's
jen and tom out on this racing boat and
our the water's coming up over the
camera housings and and i'm on another
boat with claudio next to it you know
trying to uh to film it with a big arm
and we've got a helicopter going around
and that was
that was a challenge but um
you know it was a it was definitely a
memorable one for me yeah when i was
watching it i was like oh those are real
waves this is the real you know they
look real for real
yo 100 um so i heard that you might be
doing some f1 movie uh perhaps down the
road this year i'm not 100
what what are you
is this movie happening what are you
allowed to say about it
it's really early so i can't say too
much about it other than you know i i
really love these kind of grounded
stories that you know happen in our
world i'm i'm interested in making a
movie for the big screen you know movie
that has to be seen on the biggest
screen possible
um so you know i've always wanted to
make a racing movie i think as i told
you last time we did one of these
i got uh pretty close uh on go like hell
which eventually became ford ferrari uh
that was always the movie you know one
of those that got away and um i wanted
to make a racing film
a very authentic
great racing film for a long time and so
we're we're working on it right now and
you know fingers crossed we'll be
shooting it sometime next year is it one
of these things where it's going to be
the real beneficiary of what you learned
on top gun in terms of filming with the
aerial sequences and the smaller cameras
oh for sure you know like i said every
movie for me is a learning experience
that i can apply to the next one and
what i learned on top gun is is
incredible and and so yeah definitely
thinking about how to take all the
camera stuff that we developed on this
to the next level uh what's interesting
is most people have a year or two break
between their projects um and you have a
movie coming out like weeks after top
gun called spider head um for people
that are not familiar with it um what
what is it about what what are you
excited for people to see in it yeah
what i like about spider head is it's a
uh it's not you know based on any real
known ip it's a short story by an author
named george saunders that was published
in the new yorker
and it was a movie that we shot in
australia with chris hemsworth and miles
teller and jeremy smollett
shot right in the heart of the pandemic
when everything was locked down
doesn't fit in any box um and uh is you
know it was really fun for me you know
it's fun for me to do something big and
then something a little bit smaller and
a little bit more different and uh
that's certainly check that box i'm so
curious about casting on on going back
to top gun for a second um how do you
figure out with casting and like some of
the smaller roles not that are obviously
not tom can you sort of talk about um
how you did that and i would imagine
there was just a lot of interest from a
lot of parties that wanted to be a part
of this film yeah no i had a great
casting director denise chamian on it um
and she
you know was pulling faces and people
that i had hadn't seen before or wasn't
familiar with
um some people dropped out when i
explained to them
how we were going to shoot the movie you
know uh that we were shooting it for
real and they'd be in you know real
fighter jets
um
but basically what i would do is i would
look at all the faces you know read them
narrow it down to kind of my top two or
three
and then
i would play the uh sit down with jerry
and tom and play the tape with them when
it came down the final two choices and
you know drawing on their combined
you know 80 years of experience uh was
able to kind of get the final selections
and obviously
you know i think you'll agree that the
casting worked out we got a great young
cast the the chemistry you feel between
them was was authentic it was just like
that off screen uh we had so much fun
making the movie that note i am out of
time
i will just say
seriously congratulations on the movie
uh and obviously i wanted to be a huge
hit for you and thank you for giving me
your time thank you man look forward to
seeing you soon